l'enjeu qui me mobilisera chaque seconde
de ce mandat c'est de donner une
espérance à la France c'est de faire en
sorte que les républicains soient au
rendez-vous de l'alternance au plus tard
en 2027 notre place notre rôle notre
mission et j'oserai dire notre devoir
c'est demain de reprendre les rênes du
destin d'une nation qui aujourd'hui
sombre dangereusement sur le chemin du
déclin du déclassement
nous devons nous devons dire non à se
déclin nous devons dire non à se
déclassement nous devons dire non à
cette dégradation progressive d'une
nation qui d'année à l'année depuis
2017 et l'élection de Monsieur Macron
depuis 2012 et l'élection de Monsieur
Hollande est engagé dangereusement sur
ce chemin et sur cette pente du déclin
de l'affaissement de l'apaisement notre
place elle n'est pas dans cette
catégorie de nation qui sont considérés
aujourd'hui en Europe comme les mauvais
éclats élèvent d'une classe européenne
elle est de retrouver le chemin de la
grandeur c'est notre place c'est la
seule qui vaille et c'est sur ce chemin
escarpé difficile sur cette ligne de
crête où nous devons tenir une position
d'indépendance d'indépendance face à un
pouvoir qui nous a placé dans cette
situation qui a abîmé la France
indépendance vis-à-vis de ceux qui
exploitent se déclin pour tenter des
aventures qui n'amèneraient rien de bon
pour notre pays oui notre place oui
notre seul place c'est la grandeur de
l'indépendance c'est de renouer avec le
fil de notre histoire c'est de redonner
un sens à cette histoire glorieuse pour
lui redonner un